we've been wandering down the the by
rows of HTML XML sgml all sorts of ml's
and various non ml's and last time I
think we spoke some people had wandered
off to the pub and sorted everything out
over a pint so what happened about that
then what happened next well after about
18 months the draft XML specification
was published and everybody agreed great
job didn't we learn a lot from the
decisions in HTML that caused so much
difficulty and of course the major thing
no bio means the only one but a big
major thing was that you must not omit
your end tags in XML they will be there
that being said of course a lot of
browsers still have to be tolerant about
it some people you know maybe I don't
know Dreamweaver or something might
produce a very very good XML compliant
web page but a lot of people still hand
code a lot of people particular with
paragraphs go straight pppp and don't
see the need to close off the paragraph
so you've got to be a bit tolerant but
nevertheless the idea was you do not
omit your end tags and there were about
seven or eight other rather more
technical things had to be cleaned up
from sgml but it made a lot of
difference to people implementing that
they were cleaned up one of the first
ones I'm aware of because I tend to
forget it is that in s Jim in HTML
because it was the days of punch cards
application lower case were treated as
the same so if you called it para in
capitals it was the same as para in
lower case or even you could have
capital P little a capital R little a
again and that was the same as parrot
you know that had to be clean them so
what this made possible was for the
browser implementers they loved it
because it meant that if all the end
tags were there you could do a brackets
matching operation it's a bit like in a
compiler where your match open curly
brace with closed curly brace you could
kick everything off and you could say
that
is a tree I may not understand what all
the tags mean but boy they match alright
and now that's very useful to know about
so what it also meant was that there was
a clean target for front-end software to
aim at the idea is that your
Dreamweavers or whatever but we still
aren't totally compliant I don't know
but they could say we will try and
produce really good nice XML X yes
XML notated web page stuff so what this
really means is this a diagram that we
had in the previous video can now be
extended you recall that our described
sgml has been the enabling technology
the foundations of the building in a way
and we built these applications on top
of them I did a memo I referred to the
DoD's cowls I referred to text encoding
initiative and I referred to HTML and
say you know sad it's happy L at the end
he caused so much misunderstanding but
anyway let's just extend this a bit more
now over to the right and let us say
that what the XML Committee did was to
enable as it were inside this sgml
universe as a proper subset like that
and that one is labeled XML and I've
tried to draw it wholly within the sgml
boundary to emphasize that yes it really
is a genuine subset the theologians will
say ah yes but it's subset of the
extended sgml that included several
options that Charles specified way back
and you had to have those in order for
it to work but nevertheless yes it is in
spirit a proper subset and that meant
you could generate on top of that new
tag sets or cleaned up versions of
existing ones so one of the first things
they did of course was to clean up HTML
and it's spec into XML format now
remember XML is a subset of sgml because
they're the same things the meta syntax
is
built now on top of xml notation is ex
html5 HTML and will tags matching
defined wonderful and of course several
other people tens of thousands of other
people now have been able to build their
own tag sets on top of xml technology
just to take one that's very familiar to
to me and to some of my academic
colleagues for mathematics markup again
one wishes that they hadn't bought the l
on the end but they did mam ml and power
here's a good one
adobe know what they're doing you know
poor ml on the end of things unless it's
a better language perhaps they took
their PDF technology and they made it so
that it could be expressed in XML tag
set form and that of course is called
scalable vector graphics sv g and i'll
put the dots here to show that there are
now literally I would guess thousands if
not tens of thousands remember all of
these the way you refer to them as you
say SVG is an application of XML can we
just be absolutely clear then just to
throw this in one more time what was the
big problem with putting L on the end of
these because unfortunately the two
enabling technologies end with ml and
the in-crowd something we know it says
markup languages actually markup meta
language but of course if you start
using it for something that is a fixed
tag set not a text that technology
punctuation rules so to speak then
people start saying things like oh
they're just they're you know HTML is a
subset of s right now is not a subset of
sgml it's an application you say and
people start to make those mistakes
between application and subset motivated
by the fact that they all end in EM else
and they all must me the same sort of
thing and
don't so peace broke out I think we
should say that's a long side all of
this in the mid-nineteen ninety's and
equally important it wasn't just getting
xml sorted out and thereby being able to
do HTML as XHTML properly it was also
the fact I think in that era Tim
berners-lee moved from CERN he moved to
MIT and all credit to him exactly the
right thing I think MIT made him an
offer to host basically a sort of
academic like institution concerned
entirely with setting standards for the
web and being vendor-neutral
in everything it did and as I say all
credit to him he could have made
millions out of the web there's no
question but he opted to say no I would
sooner make a smaller amount of money
and be respected and to have mine be the
standard way of doing things so in a way
the vendors can meet on vendor neutral
territory still have shouting matches
and still have bust ups but it's all
under the aegis of the w3c the World
Wide Web Consortium which is in charge
of all this I've never actually been to
one of their meetings I've talked to
once to people who've been there and I
said how do you cope with the fact that
people still get subsets and
applications confused you know is XHTML
a cut down version of XML no no no no
and one said I'm weary I'm going bald
I've got a gray beard all we try and
ensure is that everything we say on our
website is absolutely accurate and
correct but to try and get everybody in
the whole world who hasn't was going to
get it right life's too short
as Gemma's a meta notation memo is a
specific and just tell you I wasn't
lovely it's not that all this bad all
becomes good right so you have to have
this set of intermediate concepts